Okay, good morning. So today we are
doing
um the European conquest of the new
world, meaning North and South
America. Um and um so these people who
start to conquer the new world are
called the conquestadors, which is
Spanish for conquerors. These are
mercenaries. They're bandits. They're
lower lowerass people who have to leave
Spain and Portugal and look for new
opportunities in South and Central
America. Okay. So, um some basic
history. remember that um when we
discussed this Islamic golden age um the
Islamic Empire is sort of to connect the
world in globalized trade and the
networks run all the way from central um
Asia over to China into Europe and even
into parts of Africa. There's the um
maritime silk road that they create uh
because they want the porcelain from
China. They also have an overland silk
road. Okay. And at this point in
history, Spain, which is called A
Andusa, it's part of the um Islamic
world and it it is integrated heavily
into Islamic world. Um it's become very
wealthy, very cosmopolitan.
Um because of this this globalized trade
becomes much more concentrated becomes
much more rapid during the Mongolian
conquest. Okay.
And um because of the Mongolian Empire,
the Pax Mongolica um a lot of knowledge,
a lot of trade is being transferred from
the east to the west including paper
which is made in um which was first
invented in China but also gunpowder.
Next class we talk about the gunpowder
revolution which marks a radical change
in how the world uh works.
Um so um historically we have considered
the Vikings to be the first to explore
the new world. Remember that when we
discussed the Vikings they made it all
the way to present day newfound land um
and found a col called vine land. Um but
the colony didn't last very long and
that was the first encounter between the
Europeans and the native people of North
America. Um the thing that you learn in
this class that's very important to
understand is the world has always been
in interconnected in some capacity. It's
always been globalized. So we can assume
that even before the Vikings there were
some encounters between the old world
and the new world. It could have been
the Egyptians. It could have been the
Harapens of the Indis Valley
civilization. It could al also been the
Chinese. Okay. Just because we don't
have written records or archeological
evidence does not mean that there was no
contact. We have to assume that there
was some limited contact between these
worlds. Okay. But it's only until the
16th century when uh the old world and
the new worlds begin to collide with
each other violently. And the reason why
is that
um Spain was eventually reconquered by
the Europeans and it became Christian
and because of that Spain lost its trade
roots in the Islamic world. Also at this
particular time in history the Ottoman
Empire is rising in power and what's
really important is that in
1453 they conquer
Conanapole which is which was the seat
of the Eastern Roman Empire. And so now
for the Europeans to trade with India,
China and the rest of East Asia they
have to pay a heavy tax to the Ottomans
and the Italians as well. They don't
want to do that. So their response is to
discover their own roots to East Asia,
to China, to the East Indas and they do
um they hire a lot of these u very
experienced Italian um um seammen. So
Christoph Columbus is from Ginoa. He is
Italian and he was hired to go discover
a route to China.
uh and he ended up in discovering um
North America
basically. Um so all the major powers
France, England, Portugal, Spain, they
are engaging in maritime
exploration. Okay. And um start starting
about the in the 16th century what
happen is that the Spanish will start to
conquer Central America and South
America. and they do so in less than 30
years. Okay, it's a very quick
conquest. And um so you can you can see
that during the 16th century uh there's
a lot of exploration going on. There's a
lot of contacts being
made. Um the Portuguese are really the
first to establish the maritime empire.
And so the question then is why is it
that the Portuguese end up establishing
colonies in Africa, in India, in China,
uh throughout the East Indies. And the
reason why is that the fear was that
Portugal and Spain would come into
conflict with each other. So the Pope
divided the world into two. So the
Portuguese got um this part of the world
and the Spanish got the new world
basically and the Spanish obviously got
the very the better end of this deal but
that was the
arrangement. Okay. So the Spanish got
all of um present day Mexico, Central
America and most of South America. And
there's a lot of gold, a lot of silver
within these uh regions. And as a
result, Spain became very wealthy.
Okay. Um eventually the British and the
French will get involved as well. But
because South America and Central
America were already taken by the
Spanish and the Portuguese, they ended
up in North America, which was cold and
poor and inhabited by lots of very
aggressive and violent uh natives.
And it turned out that um in the long
run this would would be prove this would
be this would prove to be more
beneficial for the British. Okay, in the
long run uh but currently the Spanish
have accumulate all the wealth in the
new world. Okay. So
um the main thing I want you to remember
is that because the old world and the
new world
collided, this marked a revolution in
European agriculture because now the
Europeans could import these extremely
nutritious and easy to produce
vegetables back into Europe. So the corn
was
invented by the native people of Central
America. Corn is not naturally produced.
You have to uh basically um
scientifically invented by crossbreeding
different crops. Okay. It's a very long
process and corn allowed for the man
civilization to flourish. So corn is an
extremely important nutrient that's easy
to produce, cheap and very nutritious.
So is the potato. Okay, the potato over
time will become the staple food of
Europeans. Um, so are peanuts, so are
squash, so is the tomato. Okay, so all
these foods that we take for granted
were actually first domesticated in the
old world which was then transported to
new world. And because of these very
nutritious foods and they're far more
nutritious than wheat, you have an
population explosion in Europe. Okay, so
this is very important. I want you I
want you guys to remember this. The
potato, the corn led to a population
explosion in Europe. And what the what
did the natives get? Well, they got a
lot of diseases, right? They got a lot
of measles and small small pox. So, um,
the question we're looking at this
morning
is how did a few thousand conquisitors,
Spanish mercenaries basically, how were
they able
to conquer millions and millions of
indig indigenous people in South
America. There were three main
civilizations in South America at this
time. The Aztecs, the Mayans, and the
Incas. And the Spanish were able to
conquer all three major civilizations in
less than uh 30 years. So how were they
able to do so? Okay, that's a question
we're looking at this morning. Okay. Now
the center explanation is three-fold.
When you talk to scholars, there are
three explanations for how this
happened. It was a perfect storm of
three factors. Okay. The first is the
native people were not in contact with
the Europeans. So the Europeans brought
with them these diseases that the native
people had no immunity against. Okay?
And the four major ones are smallox,
measles, typhus, and chlora. And this
wiped out about
80% of the population in North and South
America. It was basically a genocide.
Okay, 80% is a lot of people. We're
talking about millions and millions of
people. Second major factor is that um
there were these eternal internal
conflicts, tribal warfare among the
native people and the Europeans, the
Spanners exploited this. They they were
basically used a divide and conquer
strategy against the natives, right? You
first um unite with a tribe that hated
the Aztecs. You you conquer the Aztecs
together and then you enslave the uh the
tribes. Okay, so that's a divine conquer
strategy. And the third uh factor is uh
the Europeans had superior weapons and
technology. Okay, they had armor, they
had cannons, they had horses. The
natives didn't have access to any of
this technology. So
um um that's the three-l explanations.
But
um if you ask the Spanish at that time,
how did you do it? How are you able to
with a few thousand soldiers conquer
this
vast territory? And the Spanish would
would just say because one, God willed
it. Our God made us conquerors. It was a
divine mission from God. Okay? And the
second
is we were so powerful that the natives
bowed before us. They saw us as gods.
Okay? That was a center explanation
um of the Spanish at that time. And
because this is clearly a very racist
attitude, right? We're superior. We are
white. We're here to civilize you.
Scholars have rejected this explanation.
Okay? But what I want to show you today,
uh, and I know this is going to be
controversial, and so please feel feel
free to debate or ask questions or point
out inconsistencies in my argument.
Okay? But I want to argue today that
this the original Spanish argument
actually has much more evidence. It
makes much more logical and coherent
sense than the current scholarly
interpretation. Okay, does that make
sense? All right, so this is my thesis.
This is my
argument. The religious beliefs and
practice of the Aztecs, Incas, and
Mayans made them vulnerable to Spanish
conquest. So the ultimate weakness of
these people was their religion. Okay,
you're not allowed to say this today in
university because um it's absolutely
correct. But I want you to make that
argument because I think this is what
makes the most academic, logical, and
coherent sense. Okay, that's my thesis
to you
today. Okay, so um um a quick picture to
contrast the collision of civilizations.
Okay, so the ASC people uh they're
ferocious warriors. They love war
but they have wooden spears and they
have no armor. Okay. Whereas the
Europeans they have swords, they have
shields, they have armor. Okay. So this
is a class of civilizations. All right.
Okay. So um let's go back to beginning
of time and one thing that you learn we
talked about before is how civilizations
arise because of three factors, right?
geography
um is the main factor. Okay. So, you
want to be in a temperate climate. You
need rivers in order to have
civilizations and you need natural
boundaries like mountains in order to
protect yourself from invaders. Okay?
And that's why the five earliest
civilizations are all in this latitude
right here. Okay? Right here. And they
are China, India, the Inis Valley
civilization, the Rapids, Mesopotamia,
which is here, Egypt, which is here,
sorry, and the Mayan civilization. All
right? And what's amazing is that when
you start to analyze all five
civilizations, you will discover there's
actually a lot of similarities, a lot of
common characteristics among these five
civilizations.
Okay.
Um, so yeah. So this part of the world
right here. Okay. The chopper cancer.
This is where all five civilizations
first developed around this
area. Okay. So the main civilization was
one was just an astounding civilization.
Uh they had millions and millions of
people. They spread all across Central
America. They had science, they had
astronomy, they had mathematics, they
had a written language.
Okay.
Um they built pyramids. Uh so these are
all these temples to worship their uh
their
gods. They had something called the main
calendar. And it's an astonishing
achievement
because back then they used 365 days. So
it was Egyptian was actually the first
to use a solar calendar. The Mayans
independently also created their own
calendar. And um if you actually study
the calendar um it's actually a very
sophisticated, very nuanced, extremely
scientific um instrument that they use
for
agriculture. Um the most astonishing
achievement of the Mayans was
agriculture. And this is no different
from science. Okay, they not only were
the first to invent corn. Okay, again
what's really important for us to
remember is that corn is not produced
naturally. Nature did not produce corn.
The Mayans invented corn. And this was
important because it allowed them to
feed a large population with very
limited agriculture. But not only that,
but they figure out the most efficient
way to use farmland. And this is called
a three sisters planting. Okay. What
they would do is this. They would grow
corn, bean, and squash together in a
symbiotic relationship so that they're
all helping each other uh nourish
themselves and grow. Okay. So, the corn
will provide the structure in order for
the beans to climb in order to reach
sunlight. Okay. The bean will fertilize
the corn and squash by releasing
nitrogen into the soil and the squash
will basically prevent um weeds and
insects uh from invading this ecosystem.
Okay, so it's a it's a perfect symbiotic
relationship that we still use today.
And because of this sudden breakthrough
um the Mayans were able to build a
civilization of millions and millions of
people. Okay. It was is it was it's just
an incredible
uh achievement.
Okay. Any any questions? Okay. All
right. Let's let's continue. Um as we
discussed in this class, all
civilizations rise and fall. That's just
a natural cycle. there's nothing you can
do to prevent them from declining over
time. Same process with the Mayans where
over time because of their breakthroughs
in agriculture they reach a peak uh in
about the year 780 80 in their
population but after the after they
reach a peak okay this is really
important there's a huge decline all
right and the thing that you learn in
this class is that there are three uh
sorry there are sorry uh so scientists
have looked at the reasons for this
decline and what they discovered is
ecological collapse. Okay, so you have
this huge increase in population and
this leads to deforestation and soil
erosion. Basically, they're able they're
not able to grow farmland anymore and
that's why their civilization has
collapsed. Okay, but the question then
is is this correlation or is this
causation? Right? Do you guys
understand? Right? Because scientists
will will scholars will tell you this is
causation. is because they had an over
population so they were um using too
much of the land and so it led to
deforestation and so erosion okay that's
causation I but some other scholars
argue it is
correlation and the reason why is that
mans are uh really famous for their
ecological management they're they're
masters at being able to ma manage their
environment so this could be a
correlation and not causation so Then
what's the causation? Okay. Well, if we
look at all civilizations, there are
three factors that lead to the decline.
All right. If a civilization is
prosperous, stable, and peaceful, guess
what? Three things always happen. The
first is the idea of elite over
production. Right? The Peter Turin
argument, which is that over time you
have too many nobles, you have too many
elite who compete for status together.
Okay, that's the first problem. Second
problem is the idea of rat utopia where
old people live too long and as such
young people are not able to inherit
status and this leads to a
malfunctioning of society. Okay, because
young people feel they have no
opportunities. Same thing that's
happening in the world today where in
America there's something called quite
quitting in China there's something
called lying flat tonging. Okay. And the
third is the idea of finance
financialization debt slavery. And the
idea here is that if you're a very
prosperous society, it's very hard to
get people to work because they don't
really want material goods. All they
want to do is have enough food to feed
their family and they're good. Okay?
That's why if you pay them more, they
actually work less. So the only way you
get them to work more is if you get them
into debt. Okay? You enslave them. And
that's that's what every civilization
has done since the dawn of time. Debt
slavery in order to get in order to
produce get people to work harder. Okay,
this idea of financialization. Uh so all
three things are correlated. They are
symbiotic. They work together and they
all spell the end of civilization. Okay,
this is true for Rome. This is true for
the Mayans. This is this has been true
also for China throughout its history.
Okay, does that make sense, guys? All
right. All right. Um so as the man
civilization collapsed people diffused
all over Central and South America and
they brought with them the main culture
okay because the main culture was the
dominant culture of that time. It's like
China in uh Southeast Asia. China is
this huge sun that shines light on all
other uh countries including Japan and
uh South Korea. And what will happen
over time is that um different tribes
will fight over to inherit the main
legacy. Okay? They will take they will
um compete against each other in order
to to be become the major empire. And
the nation that eventually wins out in
Central America I'll call the Aztecs.
The Aztecs are really interesting
people. Okay. So um and they're very
similar to the Romans. So um if you
think Aztec, think Romans as well. The
main similarity is that both the Aztecs
and the Romans are societies based on
war. They love war. All they want to do
is fight war. Okay. So, um the Aztecs
are originally
from southern United States. Okay. What?
Southern United States. And because of
climate change, they have to migrate to
Central America for food.
Um problem is that central America was
already overpop populated and they start
to hire themselves out as mercenaries to
the other tribes and then eventually
they came into conflicts with the other
tribes and they became isolated in a
place called Technotech. Okay. And this
basically swamp land. It's very hard to
grow food in Tennote. Um today Tenno
Techlan is called what city do you guys
know? Tenno Techlan is called what city
today? Can you guess? Mexico City. Okay.
So, Mexico City, if you have a chance to
visit there, it is actually on the site
of Tenno Techlan, which is a city that
the Aztecs founded. And remember, back
then it was all basically swamp land.
And so, something miraculous happened.
The Aztecs adapted themselves to the
swamp land and they began to
um focus on
um agriculture. Okay. Okay. And this
agriculture was very innovative. Uh they
turned basically swamp land into
farmland and it allowed for the
populations to increase and prosper. So
swampland is bad because you can't
really grow crops, but swampland is good
because it's pretty defensible. Okay.
So, so they were able to very quickly
expand their
population. And so what did they do?
Well, they started to conquer other
territories because this is a war
society. Okay, it is a heavily military
society focused on war. The religion is
to uh defeat enemies and then sacrifice
these enemies to their god who um
maintains his vitality through blood
sacrifice.
Okay. Um so the sex were known for the
most grotesque forms of human sacrifice.
They would sacrifice thousand people at
once. They would also sacrifice you
while you were alive. Uh so they would
shut you up and then cut out your heart
while you were alive. And obviously the
the entire point was terror. Okay, to
terrorize your enemies and to unite your
people. And um what's really important
for us to remember is that all war
societies including the Romans, the
Vikings, and the Aztecs practice a form
of human sacrifice. Okay, remember this.
It's very important. The Vikings, we we
we discussed how they practice human
sacrifice. Um the Romans also practice
human sacrifice. And this is something
that they sort of um hid in their
history. Um so the way they practice
their human sacrifice is at the end of
every major militia campaign they would
they would have a parade called a
triumph. Okay they would parade their
war captives across city of Rome and
then these war captives were taken to
the temple of Jupiter where the parade
would end and then they would be
strangled to death in front of Jupiter.
That's human sacrifice. Okay that's
that's that's like having human
sacrifice. There's another word for it.
But the woman said oh no no no we don't
do this. Okay, we don't do human
sacrifice because we're much more
civilized than other people and they
never explain why the strangulation is
not human sacrifice. Okay. All
right. Over time, because the Aztecs
were such a violent aggressive people,
they like the Romans were able to take
over the entire uh territory of Central
America. Okay? Okay. And they dis they
did so with allies. Okay. They were the
main partners. They part they're part of
something called the triple alliance.
Okay. So three tribes that united
against together in order to conquer uh
the surrounding enemies. They were the
main partner. Um the Aztec civilization
were was like the Romans extremely
advanced. They had uh hierarchy. They
had priests. They had uni universal
schooling. Okay. So every child was
allowed to go to school and learn to
read and write. Um they had a system of
courts and judges and they had a very
strict legal code. They have a very
vibrant economy. Okay. So this was a
very vibrant
civilization and as such their city
techn grew very very large. When the
Spanish first came to the city, they
were amazed by the extreme wealth and
size and prosperity of this city. Okay,
it made them
salivate. Okay, so this is a another
shot of Tennopekan.
Um, eventually the Aztecs were conquered
by one man with maybe a few hundred
soldiers. His name is Hernand Cortez and
he's an adventurer. He did not have
permission from Spain to go and conquer
the Aztecs. He just did so because he
wanted to. He he was a soldier of
fortune. Okay. And um when he first
arrived with the Aztecs, the Aztecs
actually treated him very very well.
Okay. He was a he was like a novelty,
right? Yeah. He had weapons, but there
was only a few hundred of them. Whereas
the Aztecs had millions and millions of
soldiers. So their king at this time uh
Montazuma welcomed him with open arms
and Montazuma probably wanted to co-op
him right. He he saw him Montasuma saw
Cortez as opportunity
uh to use against his enemies and his
internal enemies as as well. Cortez just
wanted gold. Okay, that's all he cared
about, gold. So wherever he could find
gold, he'd be happy to to go. Okay. So,
um but there was a misunderstanding
because these were two very different
civilizations. So, uh during a religious
ceremony, uh when the Aztecs were
gearing up, uh Cortez men saw this as a
threat and they start to massacre these
soldiers and one thing led to another.
We don't know what happened, okay?
Because the Aztecs were obviously
destroyed by the Spanish. um the
Christian missionaries would come and
destroy all written records of the
Aztecs and all we have are these stories
that probably aren't true. Okay, but
what probably happened is that uh the
Spanish captured Monizuma and hel held
him as a captive. Okay, they wanted a
ransom. They couldn't get the ransom so
they killed
him and then very shortly
um they were expelled from the city but
then the a disease the disease of
smallox hit the population and they all
fell sick and that gave time for the
Spanish to recuperate and then
eventually conquer the city with allies.
All right, does that make sense? Okay.
All right. Now let's go to the Incas.
The Incas um also a huge empire
throughout South America. Uh this these
mountains called the Andes. Okay. So
like modern day
Peru. Um they are in the highlands and
they also had very advanced
civilizations. Okay.
Um, one thing that made the Incas
different from the Aztecs is they
practice form of ances ancestor worship.
A pretty extreme form of an ancestor
worship. So the idea is the emperor is
divine. If you're divine, it means
you're immortal. So even though the
emperor dies, he's then
mummified. Okay? He's mummified. And so
he's still alive. And if he's still
alive, that means he keeps all his lands
and wealth. It doesn't go somewhere
else. Okay? So then now the new emperor
comes into power and now he has to
conquer new lands in order to establish
his divinity. Okay? So the Incas are
endlessly eternally expansionist. They
have no choice in the matter. And if you
think about it, this is actually a good
um strategy to reduce internal internal
um conflict, right? Because this reduces
the problem of elite overp production.
The old the old emperor's family and uh
loyal soldiers keep their land and now
the new emperor has to go conquer new
territory. Okay. So this resolves the
issue of elite over production, but it
also makes your society extremely
unstable because it's too spread out.
and um too many enemies.
Okay. Um the way that that Incas
conquered other people is um when they
conquer other people, their gods are
incorporated into a pantheon of gods.
Like the Romans, the Incas are extremely
tolerant people. You can worship any god
you want as long as you acknowledge the
supremacy of my god. Okay. So the pen of
gods. So within the uh Inca Empire,
everyone was allowed to practice their
own religion as long as they submit
themselves and pay tribute. Okay. The
Incas also had a very advanced
um bureaucratic system. They had a
census, they collected tribute, they
collected taxes, they had a legal code.
Um they had a court system. Um what's
interesting about film is they didn't
have a writing system, but they had uh
beads. Okay. Okay. And with beads with
with numerals you can create basically a
knowledge system. Okay. So this is
basically like a like a very print of
computer or
calculator. Um what's left of the incas
is Machu Picchu. If you ever chance to
uh visit there, it's beautiful. It's
it's it's it's a it's a hike. Um I want
I want to visit one day with my kids.
Okay. Uh the Incans were conquered by
another conqueror student named
Francisco Pizarro. Okay. Uh the emperor
he defeated was Ata Hapa. Sorry, I'm not
I'm not going to pronounce his name
properly. Um and what happened was that
Ata Huapa had just fought a civil war
and now he's the divine emperor. And the
legend is that uh Pizarro fought a
battle with at Hoya at Hapa. At Hoapa
had 40,000 soldiers. Pizarro had 200
soldiers and Pizaro won and captured
Atapa as a uh hostage. This story is
probably not true. Okay. What probably
happened was that um the emperor greeted
the Spanish with open arms and and say
let's negotiate and the Spanish
basically captured him. Okay, remember
in this society the emperor is divine.
He's untouchable. So it is it is beyond
his imagination that the Spanish would
capture him. Okay. Then what happened is
that Pizarro said to the emperor, "We'll
let you go if you can fill this room
with gold." And guess what
happens? The emperor issues out a
command. And a few days later, the
entire room is filled with gold. Okay?
So this place is pretty wealthy. Then
what do the Spanish do? What do you
think? They kill him. Okay? They kill
him and then they conquer the entire
territory. So that's why you should not
pay ransoms to pirates. Okay. Um it it
sort of I I think Prisar himself was
sort of astonished that there was so
much gold and the Incas could just fill
a room like that, right? And then like
well you know if I can just ask for gold
and they'll give it to me then why don't
I just take this entire territory? And
that's what he did.
Okay. All right. Um so another question
is how did this happen? How was it
possible that the Aztecs and Incas were
defeated by just a few hundred
conquesttors very quickly? Okay, in a
few decades. And um what I want to show
you now is the religious practice and
belief system of the Maya Mayans which
then influence the Aztecs in the Inca in
the Incas. Okay. All right. So um in
these societies religion is spread
through or all tradition from priests to
people. Okay. Um but fortunately in
about the year 1700 there was a
Dominican priest who uh made it his
mission to write down this oral
tradition. Okay. And this book we call
the popo vo it's translated into the
book of the community and it just um uh
it it's just a literary form of the or
old tradition the old religious
tradition of the man people. Okay. So
we're going to look at a few passages to
figure out their underlying belief
system and how it govern their society.
All
right. Okay. So this is a story of the
heroic twins. So the mains worship the
heroic twins as the savers of humanity.
So what happened is the twins h
themselves had twin fathers who were um
captured and killed by demons in the
underworld. Okay, this is very similar
to the Egyptian myth of um Orur Arsurus
um who was killed by his brother Set and
then sent into the underworld. Okay. And
so the brothers want vengeance against
these demons. And so what they do is
they become their friends with the
demons and they and then they make
themselves
um immortal. Okay? When they die, they
come back to life. And then they play a
trick on these demons. They go to the
demons and say, "Hey, look at us. We can
play this game where we cure ourselves.
We cut our heart and we come back
alive." Okay? And the demons are like,
"Yeah, we want to play this game as
well." And they all end up killing
themselves. Okay? So this is a passage
from um the po sacrifice in the same way
said one death and seven death to
hannapul and zapo zanakquo these are
these are heroic twins okay these are
the heroic twins very well then surely
you will be revived are you not deaf for
we are here to gladen you oh lords along
with your vassels and your servants they
said therefore to the lords okay so
they're playing a trick on these demons
the first we sacrifice was the very head
of all the lords one death by name the
lord of Zebaba he was dead then this one
death next they grabbed seven death but
they didn't revive them thus the
zababins took their heels when they saw
that the lords had died so they killed
all the lords and then they killed all
the demons their hearts were now taken
from their chest okay their hearts were
now taken from their chest it's very
important because this is how the Aztecs
practice their sacrifice okay so they're
trying to with their rituals they're
trying to express or bring to life this
mythology. Okay, which is what the
Vikings did as well. Both of them had
been torn open as punishment for what
they had done. Straight away the one
lord executed and not revived. The other
lord had been had begged humbly weeping
before the dancers. He would not accept
it for he had become disorientated. Take
pity on me. Okay, so this is how the
Herac twins conquer and destroy all the
demons. Okay, and the Aztecs will take
this story, they'll turn it into the
basis of their religious ritual. Okay.
All right. Uh this is a story of the
creation of the first man. What's
interesting is that the men's believe
that the gods made different attempts to
create humanity. The first attempt is by
making them out of mud and they they
fall apart. Okay, so that's a disaster.
Then they try to make man out of wood.
That doesn't work either. So then they
try corn maze. Okay, and that works. So
that's why the um uh mans consider
themselves the children of the corn.
Okay, they worship corn as something
that's
divine. Okay. Um so the gods create man
and let and let's read the story
together. Then the framer and the shaper
asked him what is the nature of your
existence? Do you know it? Do you not
look and listen? Are not your speech and
your walk good? Behold now therefore and
see that which is beneath the sky. Are
not the mountains clear? Do you not see
the valleys? Try then they were told.
Okay. So the gods created men and they
want men to be thankful. Why? Because
the gods created men in order to serve
them. Okay. So basically basically the
gods created humanity to be their
slaves. Thus their vision of everything
beneath the sky was completed and they
gave thanks to the framer and the
shaper. And this is what man says to the
gods. Truly we thank you doubly triply
that we were created that we were given
our mouths and our faces. We are able to
speak and to listen. We are able to
ponder
and to move about. We know much for we
have learned that which is far and near.
We have seen the great and the small,
all that exists in the sky and on the
earth. We thank you therefore that we
were created, that we were given frame
and shape. We became because of you our
grandmother and you our grandfather.
They said when they gave thanks for the
fra frame and shape. Okay. So we humans
are paying our thanks to the gods. Okay.
We're showing our gratitude. Their
knowledge of everything that they saw
was complete. The four corners and the
four sides that which is within the sky
and that which is within the earth.
Okay. So uh we now have knowledge and
wisdom because of the gods. Now this is
really important but this not sound good
to the framer and the shaper. It is not
good what they have said they that we
have framed and shaped. They said we
have learned everything great and small.
Okay. So the gods don't want our
gratitude. They want our subservience.
They want our obedience. Okay. And this
becomes a basis of these religions where
we have to believe that the gods created
us in order to serve them. We are slaves
to the
gods. All right? And again, this is very
similar to the enuma, the Babylonian
creation myth, where the god Murdoch
creates humans so that gods wouldn't
have to work anymore. is also very
similar to the Catholic Church which
believes that um we are slaves to god
because God freed us from the devil.
Okay. Um this is the god Tohill. Okay,
which is the Mayan fire god. And what
they believe is that Tohill demands that
we sacrifice our enemies to him so that
so that the blood will rejuvenate him.
Okay? He's a god of fire and of
sacrifice and he's always hungry. So the
mans believe they always have to go to
war to capture slaves to be sacrificed
to their god. All right? And there's a
lot of mythology
around this god. And this god has always
demanded human sacrifice. So the humans
decide to rebel against him. Okay?
They're they have they tried many tricks
to rebel against him. They all fail
because he's smarter than us. So
eventually the humans decide to get
together and to fight him. Okay? But
they all get killed. Thus only a portion
of them were able to return. Okay? Those
who rebelled, only a few were left
alive. Only a few people from the
nations were able to escape from Tohill.
At first they tried to flee. When they
were caught, they were finished off.
They were killed. It was not just a few
of the people who died. And of those
that did not die, the insects came upon
them and tormented their hearts. They
were no longer able to wage war. Okay?
So the gods had destroy capacity to ever
challenge them, to ever rebel. They did
not take up their arrows or their
shields again. Thus, all the nations
were humiliated and begged humbly before
the faces of Balam, Kisa, Balam, Aka,
and Moakata. Pity, do not kill us, they
said. Very well then. Certainly, you
shall become obedient. You shall be
servants as long as there are son and
light. They were told. Okay. So, we can
never ever cher gods because when we
tried, we're all killed. And so the gods
showed mercy to us. And so from now on
we must obey the gods. But now it's like
how do you obey the gods? What do what
do the gods require of us? That's the
question now. All
right. We obey the gods through their
priests who understand them. Okay. Does
that make sense? Okay. So so let's read.
Kokas and Kottoa were enchanted people,
priests and enchanted lords. Kopa and
Kazuma were also enchanted lords. They
knew if there would be war. Why? Because
the gods tell them. They could see the
future. Okay? They they talked with the
gods. It was clear before their faces.
They saw if there would be death, if
there would be hunger. They surely knew
if there would be strife. There's an
instrument of sight. There was a book.
Paulo was their name for it. Okay. So
everything that's written down here,
it's sacred because it was written down
by those who speak directly with the
gods. So everything all these words are
the direct words from the gods
themselves. But it was not only because
of this that they were lords. They were
great in their essence. Great as well
were their fast. In order to venerate
their temples and venerate their
sovereignty, they fasted for long
periods of time and sacrificed before
the faces of their gods. Not only do the
gods favor them, but they themselves
made many sacrifices in order to win the
favor of the gods. Okay? They are
worthy. Therefore, therefore, we must
submit them ourselves before them. Okay?
And that's how we worship the
gods. Okay? Does that make sense? So,
think about this. The logic is very
clear. The main created civilization
that extremely religious and
hierarchical. Okay? Everyone, millions
of people must worship their priest king
because the priest king is a direct
representative of God.
Right? But when you do that, you create
the condition for the Spanish to come
kill that priest king and become the new
priest king. Doesn't make sense. That's
what happened. the mains create this
religion in order to enslave all
everyone around
them and that provide the perfect
opportunity for the Spanish to come and
take over that
role. So in history class you may have
learned that the Spanish were extremely
cruel to the
natives not more so than the
previous overlords. Okay, does that make
sense
guys? All right. All right. So um what
I'm going to do now is having explain
the history. I'm going to provide the
theory. Okay. I'm going to explain the
theory of all this. Okay. But before I
do so, are there any questions about
what what we've learned so far? What
what was this clear to you guys? The
logic of this. All right. So let me
explain the theory.
Okay. Okay. So what you learn in this
class, what we what we talked about in
this class previously is the idea of
game theory. Okay, game
theory. The game theory, idea of game
theory is that all human interaction,
it's playing a game. Okay, we may forget
we're playing a game, but we're still
playing a game. So if you want to
understand how people behave, you first
have to figure out how the game works.
What are the rules of the game? Okay.
So,
um,
Samaria, uh, the Samrians were one of
the first earliest civilizations because
they were based on the Tigers and
Euphrates in Mesopotamia. Okay? And what
happened was that they developed
different city
states along the river um, the Euphrates
and and Tigris. And all these city
states had their own city god. Okay?
And these were all
different. They they all these different
city
gods. Um over time these cities came
into conflict with each other because of
trade issues. Okay. And also because of
land issues. So they start to
fight. At this
point this becomes a competition. It
becomes a game. Okay? And whenever
there's a game there has to be
rules that underpin this game. And the
and the rule the first rule rule of this
game
was we do not attack each other's
cities. Does that make sense? Why?
Because the city is a physical
manifestation of God on earth. So you
can kill the enemy's army on the field,
but you don't attack the
city. And also there are city walls to
protect the city. Okay?
And so what what would happen over time
is this game establishes an
equilibrium where okay
um they fight all the time but no one
can actually conquer the other cities
because these cities are protected by
the gods and so this this is this
reaches an equilibrium and this this is
a form of peace and stability.
Okay. And there are like these elaborate
rules governing warfare among the people
of Samaria. Okay. But then you had one
king named uh Luga Zagi who was like
screw this. I'm going to come and I'm
going to kill your god. Okay. So he
comes he sacks the city. Okay. He
basically steals from the temple. The
temple is where all the gold all the
valuables are.
and he sacks sacks the temple and even
his soldiers are afraid that the gods
will come and smite him. Okay, they're
afraid but nothing happens to him. So he
does it again and again and again and he
becomes over time more and more
powerful. Okay, so he's breaking the
rules of the game. He hacked the game.
Okay, this call hack or he cheated,
whatever. But he figured out what the
ultimate taboo is. Okay, the ultimate
taboo and he broke it. You break it, you
become God yourself. Okay, does that
make sense? The idea of taboo are what
humans must not
break. What humans must not violate.
Only gods allowed to break this taboo.
Okay? Only gods allowed to kill each
other. We humans must not try to kill
each other's gods by ransacking their
temple. Okay?
And now once this rule is broken, what
happens is you allow a society called
the
Aadians to come in and conquer everyone
because they are the most warlike. Okay.
All
right. So how is it possible for a
different people who who are much fewer
and much poorer to come and conquer an
entire empire? We discussed this, right?
the Mongols when you are um
severely uh limited in your resources
you have to use psychological warfare.
All right. So the three forms
are isolation
dominance. Isol isolation dominance just
means that you will do more than anyone
else in order to win the
war. It doesn't make sense. That's what
escalation dominance means. Second is
the idea of
terror. So the Mongols were going around
and killing people randomly in order to
instill terror uh among the population.
The third is the idea of
aura of
inevitability and
invincibility. Okay? You want people to
think you are the demon or the gods
themselves and that's how you get people
to obey you. Okay. So the Mongols
perfected the strategy. All right. But
the Aadians also used the strategy.
Sargon the great Sargon the sagen of
Akad. Okay. And what he did was he
perfected ste siege warfare to break
down the walls. And before it was
thought impossible that you could break
down these city walls but he did so. And
so this created uh escalation dominance,
terror and an aura of inevitability and
invincibility. Okay, does it make sense
guys? This this is how this is often
what happens. Um when societies are
playing a game against each other when
they're in competition, they establish
an equilibrium. Okay, the equilibrium is
held together by an ultimate taboo. But
so but then someone comes along and
breaks this ultimate
taboo which then opens up the game.
Okay. Okay. And whoever win and who's
who whoever now is able to master
psychological warfare, escalation,
dominance, terror, and aura of
ineability will win this
game.
Okay? Does that make
sense? All right. Now that we understand
the basic theory, let's apply it to the
Aztecs. All right. So the
Aztecs,
sorry
had escalation
dominance, they had terror, right?
Because of human
sacrifice and they had the aura of ine
inevitability and invincibility. Okay,
this is how they're able to
control millions of people even though
they themselves had a very limited
population. They employ the same
strategies as the
Mongols. Okay, the Incas also use these
three
strategies, right? And
so you can just say that it is really
about God. The Aztecs proved that their
god was superior to every other god.
Okay, does that make sense? All right.
The problem now is you have the
Spanish who come
in and they don't know how the game is
played. They don't they reject all the
rules of the game. They reject the idea
that God cannot be killed. They kill
God, right? They killed Monzuma who is
god of the Aztecs and they killed the
Inca emperor as well.
And when you do that, when you break the
taboo, you leave
people completely helpless. Okay, does
that make sense? So, let me use an
analogy so that this makes sense to
you. In today's world, there is an
ultimate taboo among societies. Okay?
So, China, United States can engage in
economic warfare. Russia and Ukraine can
can uh engage in military warfare. These
are not taboos. The the ultimate taboo
is no one is allowed to use nuclear
weapons. Doesn't make sense, guys. No
one is allowed to use nuclear weapons
because if anyone used nuclear weapons,
the world would end
tomorrow. All right? So
um if you think about
it there were actually a couple of
instances where we were very close to
nuclear war. Okay. During something
called the Cuban missile crisis. It was
very close. Okay. But there was a chain
of command. So maybe one guy would give
the issue the command to launch and grow
weapons. But then you have like 10 other
people who have to say yes. And there's
always be one guy who's like I don't
want to be the guy who ends the world.
Okay. Okay. So, like I know there's talk
about possibly Russia or United States
using nuclear weapons. Okay. It's not
going to happen because it's the
ultimate taboo. If anyone uses nuclear
weapons, the world ends. It's like
killing God. No one would do would do
it. Okay? But let's imagine 10 aliens,
okay? 10
aliens, just 10 of them. And there's
like eight billion of us, right? They
come to Earth on their spaceship far
away. They're they're out on the moon,
right? They are not inhibited by this
taboo of nuclear using nuclear weapons.
Okay, does that make sense? So, all they
do is use one nuclear weapon against us
and then what would happen? We would all
surrender. Does that make
sense? Okay, does that logic make sense
to you? Same thing happened with the
Aztecs and Incas. Because the Spanish
were able to kill their god, the the
everyone is like, "What do we do now?
What do we do now? We exist to serve
God. God is
invincible. But the Spanish killed them.
Which means what? Which means now the
Spanish are gods,
right? Does it make sense? So this is
what happened. It's game
theory. If you're able to figure out the
ultimate taboo and you're able to use it
against the local people, then you win.
And you don't need that many people. You
don't need that many soldiers. You don't
need that much weapons or technology.
You can just use ultimate taboo against
them. Okay? Because again the thing that
you learn in this class which is very
important
is
sorry the world
view which is basically
religion. It is the basis of who we are.
It is our operating system. Okay. that
your computer cannot run without an
operating operating system. We cannot
run without a worldview and a religion.
Okay? If you destroy the world view,
it's like cutting off someone's
brain. You you turn this person into
zombies and
slaves. Okay? Does that make sense?
So what the the implication of this is
whenever society has an extremely strict
hierarchy
where the the majority are forced to
worship
minority. It makes a study extremely
vulnerable to
invasion and conquest. Does that make
sense? All
right. Okay. Doesn't matter how many
people it does not matter how many
people you have. Doesn't matter how much
weapons you have. As long as you have a
strict hierarchy, it becomes the
ultimate weakness of a society. Okay? It
becomes you you become vulnerable to an
outside
invasion. Right?
Okay, any
questions? Is this clear to you guys the
logic of
this?
Okay, any any
questions. Okay. So
uh next class we do the gunpowdered
revolution. Okay, gunpowder
revolution. And this will mark a radical
change in how society is structured.
Okay.